a
de la Formule 1 à Montréal,
avec ses traditionnelles et
très populaires portes ouvertes.
Mélissa Francois.
- Déjà tôt ce matin, une foule
de spectateurs ont fait la file
au circuit Gilles .
Les amateurs ont même pu
apercevoir rapidement
le pilote Sebastian Vettel.
Une surprise pour ceux venus
assister en grand nombre aux
portes or le site,
la plupart vêtus aux couleurs
de leur écurie préférée.
- Je n'ai jamais vu autant
de monde quand je suis sorti
de métro une grosse file de même
fun de voir que la
Formule a encore éclat en ville.
- C'est donc le retour du Grand
Prix du Canada dans sa mouture
habituelle après deux années
de pandémie au grand plaisir
des nombreux visiteurs au
centre-ville de Montréal.
Ceux-ci viennent de Calgary.
Ce couple de Nice en France.
- Les gens sont souriants,
les gens nous abordent dans
la rue dès qu'ils nous entendent
avec notre accent car c'est nous
qui avons un accent ici!
- Et ce dernier du Royaume-Uni.
Parmi ceux qui se
réjouissent, les restaurateurs.
Ce propriétaire est si heureux
de revoir les touristes qu'il
en a sabré le champagne.ALAIN C,
Chez Alexandre
- Il y a de quoi célébrer?
Il y a de quoi célébrer, j'ai
la chair de poule, car on aquane
comme partout, mes collègues,
mes confrères, ça été long.
La moitié de mes profits de
l'année se font pendant le Grand
Prix.
- Une manne pour les entreprises
et l'industrie touristique,maist
la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
qui forcera bien des employés
à prendre des bouchées doubles.
Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, M